bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct ce matin sur rtl france
pour parler d'un thème qui on a vu
intéresse beaucoup les français la santé
priorité des français et pourtant elle
est absente des débats de la campagne
présidentielle
les professionnels du secteur n'ont pas
manqué de le souligner regarder
dans le discours des candidats à la
présidence de la république il n'y a
actuellement aucun mot pour la santé oms
rencontrent plus de difficultés que
jamais en cette rentrée ça c'est certain
l'hôpital vit une crise dans la crise
influence lassarade vous êtes médecin
vous êtes également élu est-ce que vous
constatez aussi ce manque d'intérêt en
tout cas dans les débats on sait qu'à
des propositions dans les programmes des
candidats mais ce manque d'intérêt
justement pour la la santé qui est
fortement en crise en ce moment
écoutez moi je semble pas ce manque
d'intérêt aux républicains puisque ana
philippe juvin qui a largement participé
à la crise qu'on a connu et qui
est qui est vraiment
force de proposition en matière
d'hôpital les bombes ce que ce qu'on
peut constater c'est qu'il est là la
commune n'a été qu'un révélateur des
problèmes qui étaient déjà
antérieurement très très présent et le
ségur qui a qu'a récompensé de façon
inégale les professionnels de santé a
également
exacerbé toutes les demandes des
professionnels moi sur le terrain je
suis je suis en rapport avec les
infirmières
anesthésistes qui qui se voit vous poser
maintenant là la firme et de pratiques
avancées qui ont six mois va être mieux
payés quel
les sages-femmes également demander une
reconnaissance mais en même temps les
médecins que nous sommes que nous étions
ont rempli une carrière de façon
quelquefois en sacrifiant parfois la
famille et d'autres
le salaire puisque c'est vrai que les
hôpitaux n'étaient pas toujours très
rémunérateur et final on sa tenue mais
sa tenue pourquoi parce que il ya la
conscience professionnelle
sauf que maintenant on voit des
démissions en cascade mois sur
25 saint chamond hôpital neuf ont
démissionné qui était là depuis des
années va en parler en détail on va en
parler dans le détail effectivement
alain bruneel votre sentiment sur cette
question de la santé dans les débats de
la campagne présidentielle
est ce que ça tient suffisamment de
place selon vous
pas du tout parce que moi j'écoutais
débat présidentiel est pour l'instant
tous les débats sont plus sur les
questions sécuritaires et d'immigration
mais la santé on n'attend pas du tout
sauf le candidat fabien roussel qui lui
a déjà fait le tour de 110 depuis tôt
c'est une préoccupation mais sur le sur
le plan de départ actuellement on n'a
rien cette question important une
question primordiale question a fait
entendre le cri d' alerte a été lancée
déjà vu de plus de deux ans par le
personnel hospitalier mais aussi
accompagné par les citoyens à bord dire
on manque de lits on manque de matériel
on manque au site de matha de présence
humaine est ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
mais il ya une souffrance une souffrance
qui existe dans les hôpitaux une
souffrance qui existent aussi au niveau
du personnel il ya une souffrance aussi
au niveau des citoyens parce qu'il ya de
plus en plus de citoyens qui renonce à
se soigner alors nous verrons la santé
lui et est actuellement en déplacement
en france pour dévoiler le volet
régional du ségur de la santé il était
au mans hier et voici ce qu'il a dit
écoutez il n'y a pas de fuite des
soignants des hôpitaux l'hôpital peut
compter sur le soutien de l'état voilà
ce qu'il dit je précise quand même qu'il
y avait dans le même temps une
manifestation soyez-en contre sa venue
devant le centre hospitalier du mans il
ya un décalage entre ce que dit le
ministre et et les soignants non
florence lassarade oui moi j'ai posé une
question à olivier ferrand mercredi
dernier sur les 5% de lits fermés alors
qu'en fait le l'absence de soignants ont
fait qu'à peu près 15 à 20% de lits
hospitaliers ne fonctionne pas
oui il ya une réelle différence est de
toute façon si vous écoutez ollier les
rangs tout va bien dans le meilleur des
mondes à
il n'y a aucune souvent dire aucune
empathie de sa part vis-à-vis du monde
soignants et puis des patients parce que
c'est vrai que l'hôpital souffre mais
c'est ce sont les patients qu'on ne peut
pas
soigner correctement c'est alors on voit
là ça à l'écran là en ce moment
justement le ségur de la santé 1 qui
semble-t-il est est insuffisant c'est ce
que disent tous les soignants 8
milliards pour les valises les
revalorisations salariales avec les
fameux 183 euros mensuels et les 19
milliards d'euros pour l'investissement
c'est précisément ce que promet en ce
moment olivier véran alain bruneel il ya
des actions de l'argent en tout cas qui
est débloqué mais apparemment ça ne
suffit pas il y at il urgence alors que
justement le l'hôpital et la place en
soins est primordial pour résoudre cette
crise sanitaire
il ya une urgence vitale parce que
l'hôpital est malade
l'hôpital n'arrive plus à répondre aux
besoins donc puis des citoyens mais
aussi des salariés donc en haut lieu
vers ont effectivement fait des annonces
on a l'impression que va bien dans le
meilleur des mondes possibles c'est
complètement faux parce que la réalité
complètement différente et ce qu'est ce
qui est quand même très très très
dommage car mathy je dirais c'est que le
ministère des coupes jamais les salariés
des coachs à mes soins dans des copies
cham et syndicats n'écoute pas les
collectifs sont bien en place j'ai comme
si rien n'existait et que c'est sa
politique qui compte alors moins
générique la politique du gouvernement
nuit gravement à la santé des soignants
l'urgence là c'est quoi c'est d'empêcher
les soignants de quitter l'hôpital
florence lassarade vu le contexte de
fortes tensions à cause du co lead
écoutez moi j'ai fait mon 40 ans de
carrière à l'hôpital j'ai toujours eu
l'impression que la difficulté c'était
de trouver des lits pour les soignants
un ami grâce à patrice pelous
beaucoup d'argent sur les urgences ça a
fait un appel d'air vers les urgences
mais par contre les lits d'aval les
services n'ont pas été du tout
provisionner et
vraiment on a un à
un blocage de fonctionnement ça va des
pompiers jusqu aux internes en médecine
qui au lieu de faire leur travail par
exemple de l'orthopédie pour
l'orthopédie pas ce leur semaine
d'astreinte à chercher des lits pour les
patients pour moi pour essayer de faire
venir et les alors pourquoi c'est la
grande question pourquoi ne pas ne pas
rouvrir délit on peut mesurer vie à
condition d'avoir du personnel pour le
faire fonctionner et ça se passe pas en
trois mois je crois que celle la
formation d'une infirmière ces trois ans
donc ça on peut ou trois quatre ans on
peut on nous réduit déjà anticipé et
depuis 2010 est on aurait pu former des
soignants
voilà moi je vois pas que le numerus
clausus sa compagne la sphère la fin du
numerus clausus ne s'accompagne pas
d'une ouverture de place pour les
étudiants les universités disent ne pas
avoir assez de deux places pour former
les étudiants donc je pense que la santé
c'est un problème global ça va de la
médecine libérale à l'hôpital moi j'ai
exercé à la fois l'hôpital et on cabinet
mais ça a été très difficile pour moi de
me trouver ce statut alors je pense que
tout et tout est lié et si les soignants
ne se trouve pas bien au travail tout le
monde d'en pâtir dont je pense que c'est
un confort travailla aussi problème des
administratifs de l'informatisation de
l'hôpital qui ne s'est pas fait
correctement avec des logiciels qui sont
pas toujours bons c'est la logique paris
ne facilite pas le travail c'est la
logique comptable aussi qu'il faut
revoir alain bruneel
complètement parce que moi je dis
toujours que l'hôpital et la santé n'est
pas une marchandise mais par contre les
dents train de faire de l'hôpital une
gestion d'entreprises privées ce qui
devient dramatique on demande toujours
de faire des économies sion prend
simplement ce mandat 6 depuis 2000 17 et
18 milliards d'économies qu'on a demandé
notamment au niveau de la santé
insécurité et puis 2 4 milliards émises
sur les hôpitaux ça ça devient
dramatique parce que en fait on qu'on
respecte le
vieillissement de la population ne
respecte pas aussi les besoins qu'on a
en termes de santé et donc on dit on va
faire pareil en plomb dame donc que les
tees national de dépenses d'assurance
maladie qui est une enveloppe
complètement fermé et on dira martyrs de
ça on va essayer de moi comment on peut
soigner les gens avec un moins de
soignants et moi de lui faut savoir que
depuis 2003 il ya plus de cent mille
lits d'hôpitaux qui ont été fermés ce
qui veut dire que le 100 m il y en a
moins de personnel on a moins aussi
d'offres au niveau de la santé au niveau
des citoyens et est donc on n ont jamais
à cette question oui ya une question
d'économie de l'hôpital n'est pas le
caractère le plus aux gens de ce mandat
par contre les entreprises lui ça
devient de plus importantes économies
économies passent avant tout c'est ça
qui des dramatiques moi je pense que
remettre tout à plat il faut construire
attendu
de la loi bachelot par exemple qui a
fait de l'hôpital une entreprise ah oui
complètement comme maintenant la lourde
claude café nauviale depuis quelques
années il ya toute une série de
dispositifs qui avait mal l'hôpital et
sa gestion donc il ya eu la loi sueur il
ya eu aussi
les sols touraine qui advient moment
donné il faut faire plus de 5 milliards
d'économies dans les hôpitaux voilà
découvrez en avant successives ont n'ont
pas fait des priorités de l'hôpital
après on a bien un système qu'on appelle
la t2a qui a un code parce qu'avant il y
avait une enveloppe financière qui était
donnée aux hôpitaux que juste avant 2015
après 2004 on a mis en place une t2a qui
elle est une un moyen de financer les
hôpitaux donc voila moi je pense que
l'hôpital d'avancé public sa nouvelle
pub lic ça doit répondre aux besoins des
citoyens et c'est une arme important
notamment pour soigner les patients mais
aussi pour les les soignants donc il
faut revaloriser encore plus en salaire
parce que quand on parle de ségur 180
c'est bien mais ça fait plus de dix ans
que l''indice de la vente au prix
d'abonnement tu es
content dans le chaos milliards aux
entreprises centres financiers de leurs
dirigeants publics je me dis là il ya un
choix stratégique joueurs devant aussi
un choix au niveau de l'hôpital qu'on en
fait une engeance il a fallu la
publication des chiffres chocs de 20%
dit fermé qui ont été annoncées par le
professeur jean françois delfraissy pour
que des prises de parole politique
émerge en tout cas sur la scène
politique un chiffre qui a été contestée
par le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand alors on le voit il ya plusieurs
chiffres selon selon les sources
la réalité tournerait autour de 2 6% à
vérifier voyez vous voyez ce qu'on a dit
gabriela talent il prône le bain tout
simplement l'ouverture d'une enquête
nous avons lancé une enquête auprès de
l'ensemble des établissements de santé
pour objectiver la situation et son
exploitation est en cours les chiffres
seront communiqués prochainement il y à
des décennies pendant lesquelles le
problème s'est aggravé et on ne peut pas
résoudre en quatre ans tout ce qui s'est
fait ces trente dernières années voilà
on invoque toujours le problème c'est
persistant depuis des années on se
renvoie la balle une bataille de
chiffres qui est ressenti comme un déni
de la situation à chez les soignants
florence lassarade c'est votre sentiment
également oui c'était l'objet de ma
question à olivier ferrand
les lits administrativement fermées ça
peut être cinq ou six pour cent mais en
réalité quand on n'a pas dit pour faire
fonctionner des lits existants on est
obligé de les fermer techniquement donc
ça explique la différence et cheese mal
c'est ça hein non mais quand on n'a pas
de personnel il il peut y avoir un lit
sur cinq qui fonctionne pas bien sûr le
fait d'avoir obligé et les soignants à
se vacciner on l'a vu il ya eu selon le
chiffre du ministère de la santé 15000
soignants qui ont été ainsi suspendu est
ce que ça contribue cette défiance en
tout cas vers les soignants est ce que
ça contribue à améliorer la situation
alain bruneel
non ça contribue pas il savait pas non
plus en confiance tous les soignants
donc après les soignants sont aussi
assez responsable c'est aussi la liberté
de ce vin qui n'ont pas ce back in et il
ya eu des soignants qu'ils ont aussi
proposé de faire des tests régulièrement
je pense que là pourquoi
je vantais de dire qu'à 15 me de
soignants qui ont été en retrait de leur
champion ce conflit c'est dramatique on
vend on manque de soignants parce que la
question légale au plus plus grave que
ça la question à l'autre la question
c'est de dire aujourd'hui il ya le
conseil scientifique son président qui
dit à 20% de lit qui sont fermés c'est
un sur cinq que ça fait des années qu'on
dit qu'un délit qui sont fermés c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui ça
le cabinet tient à continuer parce que
ça 1000 à 1300 lits notamment fermés
pendant la pandémie 2020 et depuis 2010
elle se rajoutent 7600 ligue ils ont été
fermées donc c'est pas d'aujourd'hui et
on continue à fermer des lits pour
convenir le délire on en revient au
problème c'est qu'on fait des économies
d'argent pour le très peu de temps
florence lassarade il ya aussi de cette
fameuse question de l'attractivité
c'est bien de vouloir avoir recruté du
personnel mais il faut aussi leur donner
envie de revenir dans la profession de
venir dans la profession
oui parce que c'est des professions dont
il faut pas cacher qu'elles sont
difficiles mais beaucoup de deux jeunes
ont envie de se mettre au service des
concitoyens donc on envie de faire ce
métier les études sont difficiles en
particulier celles de médecine on a vu
que le système pas cela ce rendez vous
presque aussi difficile que les numerus
clausus l'accès aux études de médecine
les les infirmiers par exemple
anesthésistes ont un niveau master 2
mais voient leur profession je les dis à
comparer à celle de la firme de
pratiques avancées dont on ne sait pas
qui le forme et qu'il est on a aussi le
problème des hôpitaux psychiatriques où
il n'y a pas d'informations spécifiques
qui devrait y avoir donc c'est un énorme
chantier qui prendra des années mais il
faut se retrousser les manches à force
d'attendre et de dire suivant le ferons
on assiste à un magot de souffle et nous
qui avons passé notre vie à soigner les
autres et on sera probablement pas
soigner correctement quand on voudra
quand on aura besoin de moi je crains ça
je trouve même pas le médecin traitant
pourra donc je pense qu'on a un âge d'or
de la de la médecine qui était lié au
fait qu'elle est peut-être trop de trop
de soignants mais maintenant on est
arrivé à allécher inverse et là je crois
qu il faut d'ores et déjà mettre le
paquet merci beaucoup ce sera le mot de
la fin malheureusement c'est un vaste
sujet j'avais encore beaucoup de
questions mais on en reparlera pendant
cette campagne présidentielle merci à
tous les deux en tout cas d'avoir
répondu en direct ce matin à nos
questions sur rt france